Ласкаво просимо до програми У фокусі
Європа Ми раді що ви з нами
Європа висихає ідеться не лише про
спекотні літні місяці які стають дедалі
складнішими багато країн особливо у
південній частині континенту уже
страждають від посухи і нестачі води на
дворі лише квітень в Іспанії річки вже
почали пересихати
експерти попереджають що лісові пожежі
які раніше були притаманними лише для
літа тепер можуть стати характерною
рисою весни та осені
наслідки кліматичних змін стають усе
більш очевидними на всьому континенті
зокрема і в таких туристичних місцях як
озеро Гарда найбільше озеро Італії
частково розташоване видолічному
альпійському ландшафті але притоки вже
не приносять достатньо води в озеро
це ускладнило життя таких людей як Джан
карлофучина він заробляє на життя тим що
возить туристів на різні острови озера
на своєму водному таксі але наразі
туристи не потребують його послуг
чиф як його називають місцеві жителі
усім знайома особа на озері Гарда Джон
карлофучина возить туристів по
найбільшому озеру Італії вже 40 років
але він ще ніколи не бачив озеро таким
навесні
там де колись була вода тепер люди
можуть ходити пішки на острів
Минулого року коли озеро було доволі
повноводним вода піднімалася вище пояса
дорослої людини
ситуація дуже серйозна
нам залишається тільки чекати
сподіватися що протягом місяця підуть
дощі І рівень води знову підніметься
погані новини для його бізнесу з водним
таксі
щонайменше 40% людей віддають перевагу
пішому переходу
потім коли вони хочуть повернутися назад
дехто втомлюється іти пішки і сідає на
мій човен
це єдиний човен на якому він все що може
причалити до острова сан-б'яджо його
другий катер застряг у порту
Ніхто зі знайомих чіфа не пам'ятає часів
коли рівень води був настільки низьким
як зараз особливо у цю пору року на
південному краю озера у пескири
дельгарда Іларія ерколані щоранку
записує рівень води Вона працює у
регіональному управлінні водних ресурсів
середній рівень наші 60 сантиметрів
нижчий порівняно із минулим роком
У цей час ми зазвичай знаходимось на
позначці 1 м 20 см вище нульової точки
цього року цей показник становить лише
47 сантиметрів
через такий низький рівень води
зупинилася і електростанція Що
знаходиться за кілька кілометрів нижче
по річці одразу за нею знаходиться дамба
саліон
кулані контролює потік води із озера
Гарда
звідси Я бачу шлюзи і перевіряють чи
ніщо не блокує бар'єри
тут усе гаразд
Вона відкриває і закриває шлюзи Ця вода
повинна текти звідси на поля і
сільськогосподарські угіддя на південь
від озера Гарда але зараз її не вистачає
мене досягаємо цього рівня до середини
літа
Я намагаюсь зробити неможливе Я маю
знайти баланс між потребами мешканців що
живуть уздовж озера і фермерів у Долині
це нелегке завдання і ставки високі
минулого літа спека коштувала фермерам 6
мільярдів євро
на східвідозира Гарда поблизу суаве
фермер мурено каваца дуже стурбований
черговою посухою
поля вже майже висохли
це видно по пилу якийсь здіймається коли
ми обробляємо землю
нинішня ситуація ставить фермерів таких
як мурену перед важкими рішеннями
Настав час сіяти зернові але я навіть не
знаю що я можу посіяти
кукурудза наприклад потребує багато води
а я не знаю чи вистачить нам води зі
зрошувальної системи до часу збору
врожаю ми чітко бачимо наслідки
глобального потепління
фермери та регіональна Влада зробили
перший крок вони використали кошти єс Що
відремонтувати і за герметизувати першу
ділянку водного каналу Цей канал має
довжину понад 48 км і поливає поля та
луки по всьому регіону
після завершення робіт за два роки ми
зможемо заощаджувати близько 150
мільйонів кубометрів один рік це означає
що на наших полях буде більше води за
даними італійського дослідницького
інституту 50 днів безперервних дощів
можуть змінити ситуацію але прогноз
погоди показує що Протягом наступних
тижнів на озері Гарда буде сонячно це
означає що чиф і його водне таксі не
єдині кого може спіткати нелегка літо
[музика]
зараз Іще більше людей ніж раніше
ризикують своїм життям щоб потрапити до
Європи морем багато країн переповнені
зокрема і Франція французький береговій
охороні доводиться мати справу з дедалі
більшою кількістю мігрантів які
намагаються перетнути ла-манш щоб
потрапити до Великобританії і
британський уряд хоче це зупинити вони
просувають суперечливий закон про
надання тимчасового притулку спрямований
на боротьбу з нелегальною міграцією
через ла-манш частина стратегії
фінансування патрулювання уздовж
французького узбережжя наша репортерка
супроводжувала один із таких патрулів на
узбережжі калель
час готуватися до патрулювання для цих
поліцейських це дорога до узбережжя їхні
завдання зупинити мігрантів які
нелегально перетинають ламанш вони
вирушають під прикриттям наші машини без
розпізнавальних знаків щоб ніхто не
бачив як ми під'їжджаємо
вони патрулюють групами по 6-10 осіб і
заради своєї безпеки не хочуть
показувати обличчя
моє обладнання завжди під рукою
[музика]
Я використовую звичайний бінокль
вночі із інфрачервоною підсвіткою
Минулого року 45 тисяч мігрантів
нелегально перетнули Ламанчі потрапили
до Британії
у порівнянні із 17 тисячами поза торік
для Британського уряду це занадто багато
і в рамках боротьби з нелегальною
міграцією вони надають Франції додаткові
кошти та робочу силу у майбутньому
британський уряд планує депортувати тих
хто перетинає кордон назад до Франції
патруль який ми супроводжуємо знає
операцію досконало Ми намагаємося
помітити групи мігрантів у місті
Зазвичай вони їдуть автобусом На пляж
мета вистежити переправників які
займаються організацією човнів така собі
гра у кота і мишку
вони ховають своє спорядження і
приходять за ним уночі
територія дуже велика
щастя схованки повсюди
офіцери сумніваються що нові суворі
правила надання притулку по той бік
ламаншу справді стримуватимуть біженців
від подорожей до Британії
ми так близько до Британії що коли
погода хороша здається що можна просто
перестрибнути
коли ви приїхали Тисячі кілометрів і
мета вже перед очима ви просто не можете
здатися не тоді коли до неї залишилося
лише 30 кілометрів
у цьому таборі живуть сотні мігрантів
які розбили намети щоб дочекатися
слушної нагоди для переправи
20-річний Мухаммед один із них він
розповідає Що три роки тому разом зі
зведеним братом покинув судан рятуючись
від переслідувань влади дорогою сюди за
його словами їх на півроку замкнули у
лівійський в'язниці
Це було дуже темне місце
після того як ми виходили на двір вони
ходили зі зброєю і стріляли вони нікого
не шукали просто стріляли і стріляли
вони могли поцілити в голову в обличчі
куди завгодно
вони просто хочуть тебе вбити і
більшість наших друзів загинули там
мрія мохаммеда вивчати медицину в
Британії стати лікарем
Берегові патрулі не завадять йому
наважитися на небезпечну переправу
у нас немає вибору
ми спробуємо туди дістатися а там
Подивимося як вони нас зустрінуть
Наші друзі там розповідали нам що
британці можуть допомогти суданцям якщо
у мене є мрія Я намагатимусь її
здійснити
багато людей відчувають те саме що й
Мухаммед каже Франческа Мура суд Вона
працює у благодійній організації яка
також надає юридичну підтримку мігрантам
жінка вважає що посилення тиску Британії
на французьку поліцію лише збільшить
страждання людей у Кален
минулорічне рішення про депортацію
нелегальних мігрантів із Великобританії
до ранди спричинила величезну кількість
страждань для людей
щонайменше двоє біженців наклали на себе
руки почувши цю новину
це жахливо
настала ніч і береговий патруль
повернувся на станцію сьогодні ввечері
не було зафіксовано жодної спроби
переправи вони показують нам один із
човнів конфіскованих кілька тижнів тому
це було в машині перевізника
це задня частина
вона величезна
скільки людей може в неї поміститися
думаю десь 50
щоб нести човен А ще 20 Щоб захищати
їхню групу від нас
що ви думаєте з приводу критики
британцями французької поліції я завжди
кажу нехай покажуть нам як це потрібно
робити вони не знають що тут
відбувається вони б не впоралися Краще
за нас навіть якщо у нас буде більше
людей все одно буде складно Усе тому що
узбережжя Франції уздовж ламаншу
тягнеться на 120 кілометрів тільки
навколо Кале патруль має контролювати 30
кордони також відіграють важливу роль на
острові Ірландія він розділений між
Республікою Ірландія яка належить до ЄС
і Північної Ірландією частиною Великої
Британії 25 років тому угода по белфасті
поклала край десятиліттям кровопролиття
між католиками і протестантами у
Північній Ірландії та навіть якщо
конфлікт офіційно завершився старі
розбіжності залишаються традиційно
католицька громада підтримувала ідею
єдиної незалежної Ірландії тоді як
протестанти виступили за те щоб бути
частиною Британії із брексітом ці
розбіжності знову стали очевидними
тепер боксерський клуб у белфасті
столиці Північної Ірландії працює над
встановленням миру
молоді боксер з усього белфасту
тренуються у Ледлі Холі як протестанти
так і католики
але так було не завжди
більшість молодих людей у цьому місті
виростають розділеними за релігійною
ознакою Вони рідко ходять до одних
навчальних закладів
тренер геріблек займається тут боксом
може 25 років і пишається своїм клубом
це східний Белфаст тут є діти західного
белфасту є діти з північного белфасту
вони всі приходять сюди тут вони не
заважають один одному а знайомляться і
тепер вони друзі вони б ніколи не
зустріли один одного просто гуляючи
вулицями белста
юнаки теж знають що Мирна вулицях
белфаста дуже крихкий
якщо ви проїжджаєте певні католицький чи
протестантський райони якщо вони знають
що ви протестант їм це може не
сподобатись але здебільшого цього не
трапляється вони трохи заспокоїлися з
цього приводу і стали більш терпимими
неподалік протестанські воєнізовані
формування лояльні до Британії вітаються
як герої минулих битв Вони все ще
утримують владу Так само як і католицькі
війська вірні Ірландії так звані стіни
Миру розділяють громади
бомбистріт у белфасті знаходиться в
католицькому районі більшість ночей
зараз спокійні Але після брексіту
місцеві жителі відчувають напругу у
повітрі
стало гірше це спричинило ще більший
розкол між двома сторонами громади
Оскільки ми були в Європейському Союзі і
не було кризи ідентичності кожен міг
бути тим ким хотів бути
не було кордонів не було стін не було
такої ворожнечі люди хотіли взаємодіяти
між собою але коли відбувся Брекстон
люди знову розпалили серед полум'я
ненависть Ну і таке інше
Кеті хейворд експертка з питань брексіту
та Північної Ірландії також вважає
брексіт головною проблемою для Миру
це дуже тісно пов'язано із питаннями
суверенітету Та ідентичності вони дуже
суперечливі у Північній Ірландії
Тому нам Важко пояснити нюанси і деталі
цих нових домовленостей і нових викликів
на тлі дуже простих і зрозумілих
пріоритетів національної ідентичності
браксіт приніс зміни і для бізнесу у
Північній Ірландії
[музика]
виробляє акустичні гітари ручної збірки
більшість із них продається в ЄС та
Британії браксет став шоком для Джорджа
лоудена засновника компанії
однією з перших книг думок було Можливо
ми будемо змушені перенести майстерні на
півдні Ірландії європейські Союз можливо
Нам доведеться це зробити
досі в цьому не було необхідності Я
сподіваюся що й не буде
Північна Ірландія досі залишається
частиною спільного ринку ЄС тому
відправка товарів до Євросоюзу не
викликає жодних проблем але після
брексіту деякі з його найдорожча гітар
тепер потребують спеціальних документів
для відправки до решти Британії
зрештою ми виявили що між нами
Великобританію з'явилася невелика
кількість обмежень безпосередньо в
результаті брексуту
деякі північно-ірландські протестанти
побоюються втратити зв'язок із рештою
регіонів Британії через брексіт
у католицьких районах навпаки багато хто
бажає об'єднатись із ірландською
республікою
ПАТ шиан колишній член Іра провів більше
18 років у в'язниці
Він був звільнений після укладення
белфетської угоди і тепер переконаний що
Ірландію можна об'єднати мирним шляхом
Я вважаю що брексіс прискорив дискусію
дебати навколо об'єднаної Ірландії
тому що ми побачили що двигуном і
рушійною силою брексіту був англійський
націоналізм
що саме Англія хотіла брексіту а не нас
викинули проти нашої волі
у боксерському клубі більшість просто
хочуть знати що напруженість викликана
брексітом не поставить під загрозу
здобути і тяжкою працею мир Ви не хочете
бачити стрілянину Ви не хочете бачити
вибухи ви хочете бачити що всі діти
живуть хорошим життям і ми сподіваємося
що з брекстом це так і залишиться вони
матимуть найкраще з обох світів Миру
Північній Ірландії не сприймається як
належне і брексіт не полегшив ситуацію
буде вчителем часто означає працювати на
низькооплачуваній роботі тож не дивно що
Європа зараз відчуває нестачу
кваліфікованих учителів Швейцарія шукає
нові способи заповнення вакансій багато
шкіл прийняли на роботу людей без повної
професійної педагогічної освіти а також
людей які змінюють професію такий підхід
певною мірою допомагає вирішити проблему
але багато вчительських асоціацій в
країні ставляться до нього критично і це
піднімає важливі питання про те що
потрібно для того аби бути хорошим
учителем
директор школи роль в постель витрачає
годину на дорогу до своєї школи у
венгрині багато його вчителів у такій
самій ситуації
віддаленому лаутер бруненталі дуже важко
знайти вчителів
[музика]
у нашому муніципалітеті є всього дві
школи в кантоні Берн до яких не можна
доїхати дорогою а тільки громадським
транспортом
Ось там ви бачите мюрен до якого можна
дістатися лише канатною дорогою
щоб втрапити до венгена треба їхати
рейковою залізницею
у Венгрії довелося проявити
винахідливість щоб вирішити проблему
нестачі вчителів
сільвіяна матіс родом звідси але вона не
кваліфікована вчителька
може спробувати разом може так буде
трохи легше
56-річна сільвіана вивчала туризм і
працювала у готелях
9 років тому вона почала вести ігрову
групу для маленьких дітей у школі а
зараз працює класним керівником для
дітей віком від 4 до 8 років для неї це
робота мрії
Я почуваюся дуже шанованою Я живу тут
уже 30 років і знаю усі родини Я знаю
бабусь вони мого віку знаю дітей і
онуків
діти не бачать різниці між сільвіаною та
її кваліфікованою колегою
вони обидві дуже добрі і майже не
сварять
[музика]
в принципі Будь хто може бути вчителем у
кантоні Берн
навіть не потрібно мати матуритет
швейцарський диплом про вищу освіту
близько 10% вчителів у кантоні не мають
педагогічної освіти тут у лаутер
бруненталі їх більше половини
директор сам наймає вчителів без
погодження із владою
Нам потрібні люди а не дипломи
Ми шукаємо людей які на вашу думку
підходять і ми знаємо цих людей ми всі
дуже близькі знаємо хто нам підходить
але директору все що важко знайти
відповідних кандидатів
Робін фон альман був справжньою
знахідкою йому 23 роки він має ступінь
бакалавра біології але викладає не лише
її
Я викладаю природу і технології
математику медіа та it англійську мову
до минулого тижня викладав французьку і
навіть курс під назвою етика релігія та
суспільства
швейцарська асоціація вчителів критикує
таких новачків
вчителі без дипломів вкрай потрібні але
вони повинні все ж отримати свої дипломи
каже президентка асоціації
працевлаштування у школах без
педагогічної освіти полягає в тому що ця
професія не потребує навчання багато
студентів педагогів подумають Навіщо
мені витрачати 3-4-5 років на навчання
якщо я можу обійтися без нього
більшість нових вчителів у Долині не
здобувають диплому про вищу освіту
сільвіяна каже що вона занадто стара для
цього А Робін хоче отримати ступінь
магістра і займатися дослідженнями а
викладанням просто на стороні директор
постел пишається своїми новими вчителями
але бачать і проблеми
це щоденна боротьба
звісно новий вчитель приходить з
невеликим досвідом і йому доводиться
вчитися
Це дійсно потребує часу та зусиль
важливо щоб люди не йшли зі школи через
два-три роки щоб досягли хорошої якості
[музика]
постель каже що багато нових вчителів
звільняються через рік але є проблиск
Надії за останні 15 років кількість
студентів у педагогічних коледжах зросла
приблизно удвічі Цюріхський університет
педагогічної освіти навіть відкриває
другий кампус але це не допоможе у
короткостроковій перспективі у
віддаленому лаутербрунталі вже відкрито
три вакансії на наступний навчальний рік
поки що не надійшло жодної заявки
рибні консерви зазвичай сприймаються як
дешева їжа але в Португалії консервовані
сардини - це вишуканий делікатес ця
маленька рибка стала свої рідною
національною іконою і справа не лише в
смаку Але і в маркетингу який створив
ажіотаж деякі магазини у столиці
Лісабоні зіграли ключову роль у цій
історії успіху
а на цьому тижні це все дякуємо за
перегляд Бережіть себе і до зустрічі
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік